[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
folks welcome to the Dark Horse podcast
live stream number 180 something it's
180 um four of course of course that
makes sense because the last one 183. so
sequentially speaking uh I am Dr Brett
Weinstein this is Dr Heather hiing I
cannot tell you how many things are
taking place in the world it is just
rushing past and everything is in flux
and we are going to talk about several
of the components of this today indeed
um and I'm uh excited and full of
trepidation exciting full of trepidation
well that does sound like 2023 yep sure
does okay
um if you are watching on YouTube
consider coming over to rumble and uh
once on Rumble if you want consider uh
joining the locals watch party which is
where what used to be called the chat uh
on YouTube and odyssey and Rumble that
is now taking place there we got a
moderator uh in in-house at locals and
uh I think it's uh I think it's going to
be a good Converse station there I have
a slogan for it go for it who will watch
the watch party
well not me no we can't I mean you were
juggling a lot of stuff and so we can't
but our moderator who will watch the
watch party yeah yeah but you didn't
want an answer but uh no I was just uh
it was uh uh it was a um a wink at my
libertarian friends
yes uh okay so uh excuse me we got two
sort of broad different topics today uh
neither of them explicitly scientific
but as always uh everything that we talk
about all our entire
um the world and the way that we
interpret the world is informed with the
evolutionary lens
that is true and it is also true as we
say in our book that all true narratives
must reconcile so these things are all
part of one story and we focus here and
there but uh but yeah yes we do okay so
join us after this live stream for a
live q a which will also which will only
be on Rumble and you can ask questions
at darkhorsesmissions.com removing the
rest of the stuff to the end although
I'm going to be starting up the hour
talking some about my piece published
yesterday in Natural Selections
um you go girl
yes you go girl and what we will do
today before we get right into that
though is uh talk to you about our
sponsors we have three as always right
at the top of the hour and we are very
choosy about who we agree to have
sponsored the podcast so you can be sure
that if we are talking about them here
it's because we've actually vetted for
and vouch these uh products and
companies and institutions
uh so without further Ado our first
sponsor this week is Paleo Valley paleo
Valley makes a huge range of products
everything we've tried from them has
been terrific today we're going to focus
on their beef sticks the beef in these
delicious snacks comes from small
American-owned Farms that practice
rotational grazing paleo Valley's beef
sticks are 100 grass-fed and finished
entirely organic and naturally fermented
100 grass-fed beef is more nutritious
than grain-fed beef in a lot of ways
including but not limited to that it
contains more calcium magnesium
potassium zinc phosphorus beta-carotene
and iron and it's also really delicious
if you're thinking the Paleo Valley's
beef sticks are like Slim Jims you're
wrong for one thing unlike Slim Jim's
paleo Valley beef sticks contain no
mechanically separated chicken parts
for another paleo valleys beef sticks
are actually good for you ingredients
hiding in most beef sticks and jerky but
not in paleo valleys include MSG
hormones hydrogenated oils and
brominated vegetable oil which if you're
wondering what that is it was first
patented as a flame retardant and now
it's in much of your food not however if
you buy paleo Valley
furthermore unlike other meat snacks
paleo Valley uses natural fermentation
to preserve its beefsticks this gives
the beef sticks along shelf life without
the use of harmful acids and chemicals
and with the added benefit of
contributing to a healthy gut paleo
Valley beef sticks are also keto
friendly I make a great protein-rich
snack to grab when you're on the go like
running out the door for a meeting or
going on a bike ride
paleo Valley doesn't cut Corners they
Source only the highest quality
ingredients and are passionate not only
about human health but environmental
restoration and Animal Welfare as well
and they're a family-owned company tried
paleo bellies beef sticks today or
anything that they've got we've tried a
lot of their products and they're all
great you will be so glad that you did
head over to paleovalley.com Darkhorse
for 15 off your first order I would just
point out that there is a lost piece of
History where Slim Jims and their
hydrogenated vegetable oils are
brominated vegetable oils which was
first patented as a flame retardant
those Slim Jims were initially intended
to be a beef cigarette but it did not
work because of the flame retardant this
wouldn't stay the purpose does snacks
yes exactly that was the problem
yeah
foreign
yes that was silly no it's good and some
gyms won't stay lit so head over to
paleo Valley for all of your beef stick
needs there it is
um our second sponsor this week is mud
water one of our favorites that's
m-u-d-w-tr mud water makes a fantastic
drink it's spicy and delicious and chock
full of adaptogenic mushrooms and air
ayurvedic ayurvedic I never know how to
pronounce this word ayurvedic herbs I
would say ayurvedic but I might just I
mean yeah with 1 7 the caffeine is a cup
of coffee you get energy without the
anxiety Jitters or crash of coffee if
you like the routine of making and
drinking a cup of warmth in the morning
but don't drink coffee or trying to cut
down try mud water if you're looking for
a different way to kick off your day
with a delicious warming and handsome
way that isn't just a caffeine Rush try
mud water each ingredient was added with
intention it has cacao and chai for just
a hint of caffeine lion's mane mushrooms
to support Focus cordyceps to help
support physical performance chaga and
reishi to support your immune system and
cinnamon which is a potent antioxidant
mudwater also makes a non-dairy creamer
out of coconut milk and MCT and a
sweetener out of coconut palm sugar and
lucuma the fruit of an Andean tree used
by the Inca to add if you prefer those
options or you can mix and match add a
bit of their coconut milk and MCT
creamer with some honey from bees or use
mud Waters lucuma and coconut palm sugar
sweetener and skip the bees entirely
lead water is also 100 USDA organic
non-GMO gluten-free vegan and kosher
certified
which bees usually aren't incidentally
mud Waters
are they I'm imagining the rabbis
chasing the bees around trying to bless
them and certify them and it seems
unlikely it seems unlikely that's that I
saw I'm going down a limb there but I
think it's a safe one it's a pretty
thick limb yeah yeah mud water's flavor
is warm and spicy with a hint of
chocolate plus Masala chai which
includes Ginger and cardamom nutmeg and
cloves it's also delicious blended into
a smooth that you try it with banana and
Ice milk or milk like substance mint and
cacao nibs I had one just this morning
so if it's hot where you are and it
probably is consider adding wet water to
your favorite smoothie it's really
delicious to get 15 off go to
mudwater.com Dark Horse pod to support
the show that's
mudwtr.com use code Dark Horse pod for
15 off
yes and I would point out that the
Lion's main mushrooms are now an
affordable ingredient because they're no
longer harvested from the lion's mane
which wasn't expensive and dangerous
process indeed so all right
big small Back stories of the products
that you know and love
our final sponsor this week is Hillsdale
College if you are a few years or
decades out of school thinking back and
wondering what it is you learned You Are
Not Alone
maybe you wish you had taken more time
to study topics that would be more
meaningful to you something lasting and
profound join the club
since night uh no not 19 1844 Hillsdale
College has been providing an education
that focuses on freedom and character
because they believe that virtuous
citizen that a virtuous citizenry is the
best defense for Liberty and they have
now taken some of their core classes and
made them available online for free for
anyone who wants to learn time and
Technology have changed a lot of things
but they have not changed basic
fundamental truths about the world and
our place in it Hillsdale College's
online courses range widely there are
several on the Constitution and on
Congress the presidency the Supreme
Court there are great books courses as
well as those focusing on the works of
C.S Lewis Mark Twain Shakespeare Jane
Austen there are history classes from
ancient Christianity to the rise and
fall of the Roman Republic to the second
world war and even classes on math and
logic from Euclid to Modern geometry and
one on the great principles of chemistry
I should take that one over three
million people have taken Hillsdale
College's online and courses you could
be next there are 39 free courses to
choose from they're self-paced so you
can start whenever you want in fact you
can start right now it's everything you
need all in one place with no long-term
commitment learn when and where you want
enroll now in hillsdale's not for credit
online courses program it's free it's
fun and it will change the way you
understand our country the world and
your place in it go right now to
Hillsdale edu Darkhorse to enroll
there's no cost and it's easy to get
started that's
h-i-l-l-s-d-a-l-e.edu
Darkhorse to register
hillsdale.edu Darkhorse
[Music]
so apparently I'm going to start us off
tonight tonight tonight it's tonight
where some of you are and where some of
you are listening which isn't it's
tonight somewhere
[Laughter]
um
let me start us off and I'm going to
read uh some extended excerpts from a
rather long piece that I published
yesterday
prompted by a piece that I intended to
write without having any idea what I was
going to write when I went to two events
in Portland this last weekend
um and I will stop frequently and have
us interact over them but let me begin
with just the very beginning of the
piece so that we are all up to speed as
to what I am talking about and if you
would share my screen Zach uh when
you have a chance that would be great so
this piece is called you go girl
in dragon and pink
outside on a hot summer night people are
Milling waiting for the show to begin
young and old black and white
middle-aged straight couples and
clusters of gay men attractive young
people and unattractive young people
people in various degrees of Cosplay the
fashion choices include pink everything
rainbow shorts and a certain amount of
black leather the excitement is palpable
people have been waiting for this for a
very long time
the next day at a different venue at a
different show entirely the only element
missing is the black leather
I went to both events as an
anthropologist stepping into parts of
American culture with which I had no
prior experience while anthropologists
never want to call attention to their
otherness it is generally impossible to
conceal the fact that you are other when
you drop in from my hmm from what might
as well be outer space when I lived in
Madagascar where I was not
Anthropologist but biologist I was the
focus of endless attention children
followed me the bravest among them
racing up to touch my skin and my hair
even the shy ones pointing and shouting
vasas I walk down the street white
person
it wasn't cruel and it wasn't dangerous
they just never seen anything like me
before they wondered what I was as it
was obvious to them that I wasn't the
same as what they were
on a Saturday night in Portland Oregon
this week I went to Keller Auditorium
for the work the world show put on by
the Juggernaut that is RuPaul's Drag
Race
unlike an actual Anthropologist I had
intentionally come entirely unprepared I
had never seen I have never seen an
episode of RuPaul's Drag Race I barely
know what it is don't really know the
conceit certainly don't know the players
and most definitely do not know the
culture that is bubbled up around it I
wanted to see the show without having
heard anything in advance about what
other people thought and to see it as a
standalone event
the next day I went to see Barbie the
movie
the similarities were striking
so let me just give a tiny bit of
backstory here that's you know that's a
back story explaining why
I didn't know anything about really
either of these universes before walking
into them but
I uh
I do not know what's happening upon the
screen at the moment
um
okay ah
I'm going to start over
the back story is I love live theater
and I was going to be finding myself in
Portland for a couple of days and uh
whenever I am going to be in a city at
this point I look for the live theater
that's going to be out there
and there was really nothing this time
the only thing that I found in looking
through the listings was RuPaul's Drag
Race work the world w-e-r-k with the
world
and I looked at it and I clicked off of
it and I looked at it again I thought
you know
that actually sounds like that it could
be research I have no idea actually what
this is and I do suspect that the
Juggernaut as I call it in the piece
that is RuPaul's Drag Race
helped bring in some of what we are
experiencing in the world right now
including as I talk about later in the
piece uh what seems to be an ever
ever graying boundary between drag and
trance which of course when when drag
was out there in the 60s and the 70s we
were assured it was a totally different
thing
so I bought the ticket and it was with
some apprehension that I you know forced
myself to go I bought the ticket I was
going to go I went alone
uh and before I went though I thought
because I like everyone else who is not
uh under a cultural rock at the moment
has just been blasted with the Barbie
media blitz right and I thought these
two things might have a lot more in
common than uh than I know so without
looking into anything more than what
you're just exposed to walking around in
the world with regard to Barbie I went
to the two things and what I write about
here of course is the cultural
anthropologists
sort of you know participant observation
in this case not really participant
observation but you know observation of
culture is not your own but it also
emerges from an ethos that we have
talked about a lot that we've written
about indeed in a piece called don't
look it up so many years ago we went to
a conference uh Colorado College on
field studies and gave a talk and then
wrote an uh an article stemming from
that talk about the virtues of of
ignorance of naivete and um about the
virtues there for our field studies uh
specialty film studies in places without
a good cell connection or the internet
so that you can
um
have questions Bubble Up you can point
out things uh like giant rocks in the
middle of nowhere and and say to
students
where'd that come from
what's that about what do you think
what's going on and in you know in the
last 20 years of course it's become
second nature for almost everyone to go
like let me look at it let me see I'm
sure that someone has already asked that
question and we'll have an answer but as
we have written about as I say
extensively and talked about there is
often a lot more learning to happen if
you go in relatively naive and let the
experience happen to you let the
questions happen to you without knowing
much in advance so that was sort of the
background for why I chose to attend
both of these things without knowing
much can I add a little color there
please
um so one of the this is a topic we've
come at in multiple different ways
basically at one level Reinventing the
wheel has taken on a a bad rap
Reinventing the wheel suggests that
you've wasted your time whereas in an
educational context the fact that
something has already been settled by
somebody actually provides an extra
benefit and in the case of our primary
example in don't look it up
we have a debate that raged in geology
over much of the 20th century starting
in 1922 finally being completed in 1978
where a renegade geologist named Jay
Harlan Brits had argued that the
mainstream understanding of the
scablands of Eastern Washington was must
be incorrect that he could see things
about the evidence that were simply
inconsistent with the idea that this had
been formed over extremely long periods
of time by gradual erosion like the uh
like the Grand Canyon now the point is
you can show students the evidence that
he saw without spending the many years
he took to see it and then you can lead
them to the exercise of thinking about
what it might mean
and then you can talk about what is now
known and the point is for a student in
the matter in a matter of hours to be
able to make some of the progress that
took decades to be made in the real
world and then not to have to say well
we'll never know or it'll take years
before we're going to find out and to
say well actually we can check your work
right now because since you didn't look
it up we now have your work and we can
compare it to what geology did over many
many uh many years so it is and now you
know a lot more about how to think now
you've experienced the process of
working through evidence and going down
paths that turned out not to be fruitful
or not to be true and uh and you know
maybe hopefully actually did indeed
replicate some of the thinking that has
happened in the past you did in fact
come close to Reinventing probably not
the wheel because that was a big one but
you know Reinventing some smaller things
that have happened and it you know it
begins to unravel and you know this is
explicitly about uh science really but
it begins to unravel the lie that is
textbooks right especially science
textbooks which present science as a
unfailingly linear process and you know
the scientific process which is you know
which is a cycle not a line but even
that suggests an order that always must
happen and you know we are emphatic that
you absolutely must have a hypothesis
before you take data else the numbers
that you have are not actually data
because they haven't been generated as a
test of anything
however the scientific process in
general in which observation precedes
hypothesis precedes data collection
proceeds analysis precedes the
dissemination of those results precedes
the you know generation of more
hypotheses repeat repeat repeat
has all sorts of branches off of it and
it rarely goes smoothly like that right
not only is it non-linear but it puts
the focus in the correct educational
place the idea that education is a place
where you accumulate facts that you will
go on to wield is it was always
pointless but it's especially pointless
in an era where we have access to the
facts for free you don't need somebody
to show them to you yeah then they're
now controversial but anyway the point
is it's not you're not in college to
write papers that will matter the
likelihood that you will is pretty low
right what you are in college to do is
to learn how to think and learning how
to think by traversing some route that
people have traversed before you that
took a very long time it is a and is an
accelerant right you are learning the
lessons that took them decades to learn
in the course of hours what more could
you want so Reinventing the wheel is a
special opportunity it is and I mean I
encourage with regard with regard to the
cultural anthropology
I encourage everyone to do this you know
we have
um our friend Jordan Hall actually
um from before we were actively trying
to uh was adamant
um that you need to go into the media
sources that um you are certain are not
uh do not share your your values your
beliefs your your preconceived ideas
about what is happening in the world you
need to do that because that is the
corrective to whatever the media that
shares your bias will be giving you yeah
actually uh Eric
recommended this to me as a kid in fact
he I remember his examples precisely I
was a very nature oriented kid and he
said you need to spend a little time uh
reading uh Field and Stream right you
need to understand how this looks from a
hunter's perspective
um and you know he was absolutely right
yeah you know you do find out that the
the folks you think you don't agree with
are not the caricatures you've been told
they are right yeah
yeah that's an interesting example
that's not nearly as far afield as
um you know the political examples that
that Jordan was giving us but um
but it's absolutely true that if you are
interested in conserving nature uh it is
it's hard to find a more adamant and
informed Bunch than those who go who
spend hours days weeks in nature
um with a fishing rod or a rifle in
their hands who are feeding themselves
and their families that way
um
I have not actually figured out which
which pieces to read and which to skip
um so I'm gonna I'm gonna do this little
piece here so that's all sort of set up
and then mostly I'm going to focus on
the barbie part of this can you answer a
question for me first though I may not
be the only person with it or maybe I am
yeah as little as you knew about
RuPaul's Drag Race I may know even less
okay is it a television Pro I mean I've
heard the term RuPaul's Drag Race it's
yeah it's a it's a I I think it is
probably correctly referred to as a
reality TV show
um
uh at least that's how I understand it
now having seen
um just a basically the maybe I should
just read this
um
everything has become spectacle
before Showtime at the Keller Auditorium
the music is intense booming distorted
at least this close to the stage in the
shadow of massive speakers beams of red
light sweep over the crowd and the giant
screen as digital drag dystopia on
endless repeat
finally the show starts a short high
energy dance number with a dozen drag
queens people wearing personas that are
known by a large fraction of the
audience so that's the thing like it
seemed like most the audience knew all
the drag queens who showed up so they've
been on past Seasons I think there's
like 14 or 15 seasons of RuPaul's Drag
Race so they've been on past Seasons
they were crowd they were favorites or
not I didn't even know but you know
people cheered when these people came
out when the drag queens came out they
were clearly known by the audience
these Queens are famous but they're
famous in the way of all reality TV
stars famous for being famous and for
some exaggerated aspects of their
personalities
the show is primarily a series of dance
numbers most with a single Central drag
queen plus six accessory dancers two
women and four men the accessory dancers
are excellent at what they do and they
work hard hopefully the gig pays well
most modern dance doesn't I think in
qual involve quite so much twerking and
writhing and grabbing of crotches
whenever a new act comes on stage the
audience screams in ecstasy like so many
teenage girls some of the drag queens
have moves to be sure a few of them are
beautiful even at least from this
distance Asia our host for the evening
is among them
but the audience screams especially hard
for the obese drag queens the obese drag
queens have rolls of fat
and when they jiggle their fat
suggestively the audience Roars its
approval when they grab their own
crotches they get more screams when they
make suggestive movements with their
tongues four screams and one of them
improbably and impressively does the
splits the response is nearly ear
shattering other than that one move
though the obese drag queens demonstrate
little in the way of skill and yet they
are adored
after intermission two amateur drag
queens are brought on stage from the
audience they are going to lip sync for
your life
it's a competition which the audience
will judge the first queen is polished
and immaculately put together with tall
black boots so elaborate that Asia
comments in them improvingly
he's a tall leggy Brazilian with long
perfectly straight blonde hair he sort
of he does this drag queen flip of the
hair that I sort of think I associate
with drag queens even though I'm not
sure I've ever seen a drag show
it's got perfectly straight long blonde
hair
um and lip sync's weld whose song he
didn't know was coming he also knows how
to move
the second amateur drag queen they
pulled up on stage does not have the
moves and mostly fails to lip sync at
all while jiggling his bits he is also
obese and what he has in addition to his
fat is the presumption the people will
love him he is right they do
the audience overwhelmingly gives him
the win
objectively he wasn't nearly as good as
the first guy but that presumes that I
understand what the game is clearly I do
not
the OB sandwicher drag queen does know
the game though and plays it well or
rather he works it he does it so well
that I know his name Charisma with a K
but do not know the name of the more
skillful Queen who lost the game I guess
is about being something so loud and so
Brash that others will fall all over
themselves to demonstrate their
Adoration of you loudness and brashness
and simply not being as you're expected
to be is now sufficient to earn
adulation if you choose to claim that
ground
it's a way of telling the system off
without having to have any clarity about
what the system is or why you're angry
at it in the first place
Charisma with a K earns a solid you go
girl vibe from the audience
you go girl would seem to be a statement
of female empowerment
I'm not convinced it seems to me at best
to be a celebration of that which is
immutable those things you did not earn
and did nothing to change at worst it's
a celebration of poor choices and
unfortunate outcomes
so
I don't know how you're looking at me
it's a thoroughly disturbing picture
that you paint
um and especially I mean I know that
this is the the subject of your essay
but
um it is especially disturbing in light
of the uh the Preposterous conversation
the sophistry surrounding transness and
even more so uh having this take place
in Portland where everyone at least
overtly is so thoroughly uh believing of
these incredible claims so anyway the
newly elected governor of Portland
no the newly elected governor of Oregon
Tina kotec I have seen has just I don't
know if she has proposed or has managed
to push through
sincerely hope not
that children as young as 15 should be
allowed to get trans affirming Health
Care without consent or knowledge of
their parents
so
Tina kotech never would have been
elected without Portland the rest of the
state doesn't buy into this crap Eugene
I guess but um but Oregon is a is a big
western state with one massive City and
it's not even that massive but one one
big city and
um the ethos the Statewide ethos is
becoming the Portland ethos and that
fits very well with what
seems to be happening in the audience at
this at this work the world show uh a
complete abandonment of
of reality I guess and
and the idea and you know that wasn't
the most surprising thing I saw get to
that but the but the idea that
drag which I've never liked the idea of
like never uh that even even though I
love David Bowie right and I'm
remembering the movie Victor Victoria
must be from the early 80s with Julie
Andrews playing a down on her luck
um
act performer of some sort who uh I I
think the conceit of the film is she
goes in drag to perform but then she's
in Dr then she furthermore puts on a
female
um she plays a man playing a woman right
um and and it reveals this you know this
onion-ness of of human identity and
personality and what you what your eye
thinks and what your brain thinks and
what you can you know how you know to
what degree does it matter but
it's never there's never a confusion
there and Bowie was never confused right
I thought you know what what the
character actually is these were
conscious attempts to play on
um gender roles take that term to be
right prior to the current battle over
them these were conscious that nobody
was trying to fool anybody
um and it's interesting you know the
mind is strange in this regard so I
don't know how many what percentage of
straight men I speak for here I'll speak
for myself but I would bet that this is
uh largely resonant
a woman wearing a man's shirt can be
very sexy the woman
wearing a mustache horrifying right it's
like why does the Mind distinguish
between these two things and so anyway
an intelligent person like David Bowie
playing on these tropes is revealing
things about your own construction
um and you know there are things worth
knowing he never thought he actually was
Ziggy Stardust right it was a character
yeah exactly so um that they're in
throughout history and pre-history
presumably there will be uh intentional
uh playing on tropes which is very
different than attempts to mislead and
of course all of Cinema all of fiction
right you know is in some sense people
you know you walk in there with a
suspension of disbelief and you accept
that these characters are who they say
they are yeah and I guess
requires like you can't be asked to
continually suspend your disbelief over
and over and over and over again on
multiple different topics right the you
know a fictional world that you want to
immerse yourself in that the filmmaker
or the writer is asking you to immerse
yourself in is welcoming you into
um
will only work if you suspend your
disbelief sort of once it could be at a
global level it couldn't be about
everything right but once your brain
can't continually be being called you
know repeatedly called to like wait what
was that what's going on you can't you
can't be asked to increase the level of
suspension repeatedly without breaking
the illusion and you know I talk later
in this film
um about uh later in this piece about a
film from 1974 a surrealist film from
Goodwill called The Phantom of Liberty
um and maybe I'll maybe I'll end up
reading this whole thing but
um
it in which you know a lot of European
New Wave Cinema in the 60s 70s was
explicitly playing with social norms and
great
but
I think many of the thinkers in that era
and of course this is the same era that
we get a lot of The Originators of
actual post-modernism made the mistake
of imagining that if some social norms
are both culturally created and past
their sell-by date then all social norms
must be culturally created and passed
their cell by date and that's not true
that is that is a a false conclusion and
it may be fundamental to the whole error
of post-modernism like you can be right
like you can be right about some of
these critiques that language can help
create social norms and that the you
know the panopticon that we're living in
is not good for most of us right but
that doesn't mean that your
Insight applies universally to
everything that humans have ever done
and that's the world we're now living in
so it's obese drag queens like obese
drag queens that don't appear to have
any skill by the you know and I I admit
freely like I don't know what the game
is I don't know you know what they think
they are doing but to have two amateur
Queens get up on stage and have one of
them look to me like I remember drag
queens looking and uh and he looks
compelling
and to have the audience overwhelmingly
through their through their votes with
with cheers at the end vote for the guy
who couldn't even lip sync and that was
what the game was said it was to be
about
what is it then what are what is it that
we are being asked to buy into it the
whole thing and again I say this later
in the piece the whole thing feels like
a dare like call me out on this call me
out and the fact is most of us who
aren't into this aren't looking at all
and then a lot of us who are looking at
it going like wait what did I miss like
no no you know what just like just like
when I would when when I had students
who didn't have much background in
science and I would insist that they
were reading the primary literature
right but I didn't give them textbooks
you're going to be reading the primary
election well I can't assess that you're
going to learn how to and they come to
me and say I just I don't understand it
and sometimes they didn't understand it
because they didn't have the background
very often they didn't understand it
because it was written terribly and was
written to confuse because a lot of the
scientific Literature Like A lot of the
technical literature everywhere is
written by someone who has something to
hide doesn't really know what they're
talking about and doesn't really want to
be called out on anything that is in
what they are putting out there and so
just you know giving students
appropriate not inappropriate but
appropriate confidence to say actually
this conclusion here does not follow
from the evidence that you have laid out
and that's on you not me that's a you
problem not a me problem this scientific
paper is not good like I feel like
that's the framing with which we should
all be looking at things like
with your peace drag queen win now the
sticks seem like they're lower here but
maybe not because I feel like everywhere
we're going now in society we're being
told oh yeah yeah a looks to you like
it's better than b in every regard but B
is winning like what why so you've given
me no evidence
I mean I think you
you're calling attention to exactly the
right question and it doesn't really
matter that this is low stakes in fact
it could be zero Stakes because the real
point is that it is diagnosing the
audience that's the really important
thing okay
um and what I wrote down here is
the game is the game more broadly than
RuPaul's Drag Race
is suspend your disbelief or else
that's what we are being told but not
just suspend your disbelief or else
suspend your disbelief and now another
thing and another thing another thing
it's like the progressive stack meets
suspend your disbelief and oh now it's
uh now you got to be disabled or else we
don't love you now you gotta you know
now you got to be obese or we don't love
you now whatever it is but I think this
this this proves the point because
when you go to a movie
right and when they cause when they say
we are living in a magical realm and
people cast spells and those spells have
consequences for reasons we're not going
to explain that's the level at which you
suspend your disbelief
um and then they up the level of
disbelief to something uh you know they
invent a character to explain some error
that they've made earlier in the story
right and the point is well now I just I
have fallen out of the belief that I
create the disbelief uh state which I
had suspended yes and you've broken the
illusion you've broken character in the
middle of the thing and I'm no longer on
board so I don't know what it cost to go
to a movie these days but you've wasted
my money yeah 12 13 bucks suspend your
disbelief or else is about something
else it's about safety right you're
gonna suspend your disbelief this is a
threat the threat is if you cannot
suspend your disbelief about men turning
into women you're a problem and you're
going to end up on the wrong end of this
mob right so how do you explain an
audience there's a bunch of men and
women face who are going to come at you
right so yeah
how do you explain a Portland audience
signing up to go see this thing and then
voting for a much lesser and much less
compelling version to win a competition
that is ostensibly about being more
compelling what this is is an
opportunity to Virtue signal I'm better
at suspending my disbelief than you are
and so the point is it is the threat
that they feel that is causing them to
embrace the least compelling version to
prove even in that case oh that looks
like a woman to me
but I mean it's also true that and I did
not
I did not talk in this piece about what
I saw in the audience
um
you know there's a there's a lot that I
saw and I thought and that did not end
up here
um but as you might imagine
uh the crowd had some uh beautiful and
compelling people in it including for
instance some guys who looked like they
walked out of the Castro in the 1980s
like some some just fabulous gay guys
really really built wearing like black
leather and you know like could have
been the Village People right uh but it
also had the you know
2010s 2020s version of this the woke
Brigade The you know the so-called queer
Community if you will which
and large these people do not look
healthy right it's you know people are
you know very doughy very pale you know
lots of artificial color on their
skin and their hair and such and um some
elaborate costuming which okay but often
not just kind of dingy clothes and
doughy both affect and physique and at
some level I think that people have
become convinced that to Aspire is
somehow shaming those who haven't done
better and so by voting for The
obviously less compelling less skillful
and less attractive person they are both
affirming who they are
and not
fat shaming Beauty shaming you know all
of these things which is actually just
code for uh if you are fit and healthy
and look good you don't get to talk
about it because I'm in charge now and I
don't have health I don't have Beauty
aren't apparently you know often don't
have much going on at all but I've
declared that I'm in charge and somehow
a lot of people are buying into it well
there's a a generalized theme across
multiple things that we have talked
about uh in the last couple years
you've got a population that is by
whatever mechanism actually being
sabotaged in its attempt to do what
people used to do automatically try to
look good try to be strong to have
virtuous characteristics to be capable
to achieve things in the marketplace uh
you know now you can make all kinds of
critiques about that system and how well
it works how fair it actually is what
you do about the fact that people are
often hobbled through no fault of their
own but when you have a large fraction
of the population
that is let's say
obese because of factors that they've
never been able to identify you know
impurities in their food uh jobs that
cause them to be sedentary light regimes
that cause them to misunderstand what
part of the year they're in who knows
what the factors that contribute to such
a thing might be but when you have
people who know that there is no switch
they can flip there's nothing they can
do they are just simply in this state
then of course an attack on the idea of
better and worse sounds appealing
wouldn't it be great if I just didn't
feel awful right yeah I mean I guess I
it's not either or so you know you you
and I
um to the Chagrin of some
uh mostly right of Center people uh
correctly point out how much of the
Obesity epidemic is actually about
conditions and parameters that happen to
people when they are children and don't
have any choice in the matter and that
it is very very hard
to fully undo those things
may be impossible to fully undo those
things
however
you can begin making different choices
now and everyone should begin making
different choices now if they are uh
unhealthy oh of course I'm not arguing
against that but the problem is that
that
pattern that people should adopt is one
that requires an extreme taste for
delayed gratification right that there
is there's no set of
choices you can make today that are
going to have you feeling substantially
different by this evening right so the
point is you're talking about changing
patterns of behavior that over the
course of years of dedication will
result in Improvement and who knows how
much some people achieve great things in
this way but it's really really
difficult and so all I'm saying is that
there's a siren song on the rocks and
the siren song says that you know what
the whole set of Notions that we grew up
with that some people are more beautiful
than others that some people achieve
more because they're more capable than
others all of that was nonsense it was
an excuse and the problem is that that's
not total [__] right there's an
awful lot of rent seeking that makes
people Rich did those people contribute
more is that why they're rich no some of
them not at all right some of them are
rich and some of them are explicitly and
only parasitic right many of them are
only parasitic some of them are actually
did something that accounts for 15 of
their extraordinary wealth and the rest
of it was the result of REM seeking
that's not uncommon so the point is for
those who are not in a position to do
anything to control their trajectory
they're basically planktonic they're
drifting through the economy they're
drifting through their business
they're not even in a position to seek
rent but but the point is for the for
the person who is helpless because they
just didn't they weren't born into
circumstances where they had the
resources to do it and they've been you
know bombarded with chemicals that are
misinforming them and school didn't help
and all of the stuff
the idea that maybe it was all [__]
all along there's an awful lot of
[__] maybe it's just all [__]
yeah right that that is very appealing
that actually fits um
I'm gonna I don't think that fits with
the next section but that we're going to
come back to that
um Let me let me read the next section
uh you can show my screen here um and at
the top is a picture of one of the um
one of the drag queens uh who was at the
show mistress Isabel Brooks this was the
crowd favorite
um in Barbie land 2 everything is
spectacle it's a movie so pink it caused
a global shortage of pink paint
as with work the world I am neither the
intended audience nor familiar with the
universe from which the confection
emerges once when I was little a
well-intentioned family member who was
unaware that I had no interest in dolls
gave me a Barbie as a birthday present
she had loved her Barbies and assumed
that I would too I put the Box slightly
aside and never saw the thing again
that said much of the movie is
entertaining and fun not deep but not
dark but then it doesn't pretend to be
either problem is it sneaks in a whole
lot of wrong and people accepting wrong
things because pop culture sold it to
them with popcorn and a coke is part of
how we got to the very dark place we
were in today
first drag was sold to us as some sort
of post-feminist fetish and now so is
Barbie
Barbie the movie begins with a remake of
the opening scene from Kubrick's 1968
Masterpiece 2001 A Space Odyssey
instead of a monolith Paving the way for
Apes to become conscious space traveling
humans we have Barbie as harbinger of a
whole new world for girls
I thought the Barbie's impossible
measurements and laughably absurd list
of achievements were demeaning to women
not aspirational but the beginning of
this movie but happy believe that I've
got it wrong apparently Barbie is the
feminist icon we've all been waiting for
mid-film the Ken's take control of
Barbie land and convince most of the
Barbies to do the Ken's bidding Margot
Robbie's appropriately gorgeous
stereotypical Barbie has her dream house
stolen and turned into a Mojo Dojo Casa
house a real bro Palace
understandably she falls into a funk
which manifests as lying face down on
the floor a few of her golden locks
slightly out of place
in answer to the question of why she is
immune to the brainwashing that has
turned the rest of the Barbies into can
accessories stereotypical Barbie moans
either you're brainwashed or you're
weird and ugly there is no in between
fantastic
this does fit this isn't this isn't
exactly where you ended with with what
you were riffing on but this does fit
with the
the conclusion from many who have been
betrayed
feel betrayed and many of them have been
betrayed by a world that did not offer
up what it promised
they and this again is a point that I
have made many times before they find
binaries where there aren't any and they
reject the binaries the few binaries
that actually exist in the world right
like male and female is the binary sorry
it's not going anywhere but either
you're brainwashed or you're weird and
ugly
what a horrifying vision
and you know this is stereotypical
Barbie in a funk and of course not
looking weird or ugly at all she's got a
few locks out of place right
um so you know there there is a bit of a
spoof here but
um weird Barbie played by Kate McKinnon
uh responds to that with something like
oh don't I know it so you know we're
thought we're simultaneously supposed to
understand like oh this is a joke we
know this isn't true but then also be
told
um by the character that we're kind of
rooting for because she's she's the
weird one who's kid in the real world
who's cut off her hair and put marker on
her face
um that you know she she knows some
stuff about life and yeah it's true it's
true stereotypal stereotypical party
Barbie Barbie you were brainwashed and
now you're never gonna be again and uh
and too bad for you
well I I hate to say this because I
don't I don't like the world that it
suggests but the conservative Trope
about the ugliness of
liberals
um reflected in what Barbie says here
uh
would fit rather well with the idea that
we've been developing over the course of
weeks that there is something about the
Hemorrhage of
um antipathy for Success that we see on
the blue team right that the attack on
those
the reason that you end up on that team
what I
I'm not sure I'm happy I called team
loser but it does seem to be an
accumulation of people who are rebelling
against the idea of Merit and success
because they're not in shooting distance
right and you
okay so I I do see that and it's
unfortunate I don't like it either I
think it's true but you know there's
there's at least one giant caveat here
which is that
um
at least as I've understood it in the
past and I don't know that it has
changed
the conservative version of female
Beauty
has been a
an artifact it's been a fiction it's
been highly made up highly dysfunctional
I mean it's it's been a Barbie like
thing right like that you know the the
conservative
talk show hosts and such
um look like they wouldn't know
begin to know what to do with a
screwdriver if you hand it to them right
like they just they have would have no
idea and you know the heels the nails
you know makeup doesn't uh inherently
impair your ability to do anything
um but you know everything about it is
you know woman as accessory and uh in
like now I think you're right there's so
much Embrace of unhealthiness yeah of
you know fat is beautiful you know all
of these things are are just in being
embraced by team loser if you will
um but there are plenty of beautiful
women on the left who don't look like
those conservative icons look because
they we refuse mostly to put on heels
and make our hands non-functional by
having long nails in the end you know
that fragile income and you know from
fragile you get to and probably
incompetent because how would you become
competent if you were always dressed in
a way that you couldn't possibly get
anything done
so so
you know that's a giant caveat to a
point that I think is basically true
well so I want to flesh out this picture
a little bit yeah one thing I I disagree
with you slightly on makeup is not
um doesn't get in the way of doing
things for the following reason well it
doesn't in the way of heels or long
nails right it does not physically
impede your ability to do things but the
time necessary to do makeup properly is
hobbling sure there's opportunity cost
you know let's just say that you know
conspicuous consumption is what it is
that the meaning of long painted nails
that are easily broken is absolutely
transparent right the point is I do not
my value does not come from working with
my hams right and and and make up like
the color on the nails uh reveals if you
have you know made an error and gone and
done anything it's like Oh My Nails
chipped I must have you know done
something physical in the world right
right so anyway that is what it is it
comes from where it comes from and it
doesn't have to mean the same thing and
modern times but that is where it
obviously began yeah um
the funny thing or the tragic thing here
is as we've discussed
the West did really well actually
freeing women to participate fully in
the creative Dynamic parts of
civilization we succeeded in this really
well right you find women are I don't
know what the exact percentages are but
they've reached parity and in some cases
exceeded it in graduate school in
medical school in law school the point
is women have gained the they have
gained agency over how their time will
be spent and that is a major achievement
in a short period of time it's
asterisk note that your examples and
they aren't the only examples to be had
but your example is all involved school
and this unfortunately
um you know this is a downstream effect
that presumably the dudes in charge
around the turn of the last century uh
from the 1800s the 1900s never imagined
when it was you know women being shunted
into sort of school teacher roles like
well now we have school that's really
not particularly good for boys and men
and and here we are well look I of
course agree with all of that but but
the basic point is look did we achieve
Perfection on the sex and gender front
no but did we make shocking levels of
gains in a shockingly short period of
time we absolutely did and you know many
of the the you know let's take Megyn
Kelly for an example
Megan Kelly is lovely she's wonderful
she's wonderful she is high achieving
incredibly intelligent she does have
that kind of
um I don't know no she's she's wonderful
I'm not saying she's not wonderful what
I'm saying is that the the picture you
painted of uh you know conservative
um
anchor women right
all I'm saying is beauty standards over
in that quadrant are simultaneously
accurate in some sense with respect to
uh human perceptions of course some of
that is Downstream of culture that sets
those standards but objectively
beautiful people
um but
you know Megyn Kelly is not asking to go
back to the kitchen she is a high
achieving career woman and fighting
fiercely on a stage that used to only
include men I think the example of using
anchors which I raised first is is the
wrong one because anyone in front of
making a living in front of a camera is
going to be made up and you can't see
the heels but you can kind of infer them
yeah
um
walking around the world
uh what is more often true of
conservative young women versus liberal
young women 20 years ago 30 years ago
was that the conservative young women
were more likely to be to be made up to
look like dolls right right and uh even
then you know now it's unfortunately
increasingly true but even then the
conservatives were saying ah Liberals
are ugly it's like no we don't have
makeup on what you're seeing is a farce
what you're seeing is a mask do you want
a mask or do you want a person
right
um
but the question then with respect to
the two events that you attended I think
and I think
I don't want to paint it too cleanly
because it's obviously really broken in
one way but I see two failure modes
right one of these is the blue team
failure mode in which uh you know
sex and gender are the invention of
something oppressive and we're going to
play with every Trope and what's more an
ugly person is beautiful if we say so
and we'll all cheer to prove that we
accept this all of that the other is
some you know Barbie is not you know an
ivory girl she's not girl next door
right this is in some ways a
conservative view of what feminine
beauty is supposed to be and in its own
way deeply troubling for that reason
because it does not include the
achievements that women have made in uh
participating in but that's not true
right so I mean Mattel has been
rebranding Barbie since the beginning so
like I mean no no I I understand humans
are part of the Barbie Juggernaut now
right of course they are of course but
it's part of what makes the whole thing
so demeaning right it's like
you spent an hour this morning looking
like that and you're a Nobel Prize
winner
that's not a thing it's and you're how
old and you're the president like it's
it's just incoherent it's kind of like
remember that doll like math is hard was
that a Barbie I don't remember if that
was a Barbie but there was some there
was some kerfuffle legitimate kerfuffle
uh where some doll company put out a
doll that you could pull a string in her
back and and uh the Girl doll said math
is hard like oh for [__] sake sorry
but like like this is this is it is it's
just reifying all of the things I agree
it is achievement as affectation which
is offensive yeah okay so
there's no question in my mind that what
you saw at the RuPaul Drag Race thing
was a you know imagine a bowling alley
there are two gutters you can end up in
one of them is the Portland dystopia uh
where sex and gender is an invention of
the patriarchy and we're uninventing it
because that's what's liberating and all
of that and the other is something that
is happening over in conservative space
which is a in my opinion
ham-fisted defense of more traditional
feminine tropes and the real point is
actually neither of these things work
yep nobody rational I think wants women
back in the kitchen right taking a
secondary role in Civilization there's
no the gains we have made are not only
really important from the point of view
of women but they've just been important
to planet Earth but just as you were
talking about I think last week with
regard to
uh what you were calling Nazi Twitter uh
you know those voices those those people
who do want women to be in the kitchen
and nowhere else except the bedroom uh
are getting more and more vocal and you
know more and more
um well that's that's the thing in the
absence of a coherent forward-looking
program in which we acknowledge hey
liberals will write about some stuff you
know what they were right about that it
was a really good idea for women to be
liberated to do what women want to do on
the other hand there were aspects of
this that didn't work right the sexual
revolution had massive unintended
consequences that we are now suffering
from and so we need some sort of new
forward-looking mechanism for recovering
the games on what we did right and
fixing what we did wrong and not going
backward and the problem is in the
absence of that Vision what you have is
pick your dystopia right is it Barbie
dystopia or is it RuPaul dystopia and I
don't think RuPaul is inherently
dystopia right RuPaul is old enough that
RuPaul was traditional drag which sure
was never my thing either but the point
is is there any harm really in guys
dressing up as women and you know
parading themselves in front of an
audience I don't know but I think the
harm was well I guess increasingly
um
I do Wonder
how it is that we have arrived at a
moment
a cultural moment where it is
universally understood that blackface is
wrong right and
it is you know almost widely pushed
That Woman face is not just fine but
honorable yep I
increasingly do not see the difference
well the problem here is that we have
screwed up the blackface problem right
because it is such a flash point the
point is a Prohibition against all
blackface is almost sensible now it
becomes not sensible when we talk about
the character Roger in
um in Mad Men Who has to put on
blackface to portray a prior World in
which blackface was a thing but the
problem is Minstrel show is inherently
mocking of black people right that's the
reason that blackface has the
connotation that I haven't just been in
a drag show yep I would say that drag
show is inherently mocking of women
that's that's that's the position I'm
arriving at so
um this this is this I agree but the
point is even buried within the question
of drag versus
trans
the problem is
we know trans people who
adopt the demeanor of the other sex and
they do not do so disrespectfully and
then we know others who do so
disrespectfully and that I guess my
point is you can't make a rule based on
whether or not somebody is respectful or
not because how would you how would you
be able to establish it one way or the
other which is why we get into these
false binaries but there are at least
two motivations there let me read I'm
I'm not going to end up reading the
whole thing but I've got two more
sections sure let me read the first of
the short of the two sections
while feminism is getting a facelift
over in Barbie land RuPaul's Drag Race
is playing at the boundary between drag
and trance
these are men dressing as women not men
who think they are women right right
sometimes it's not particularly clear
some of the RuPaul drag queens my scant
post event Googling revealed have indeed
come out as trance
the distinction is whether the
caricature of Womanhood that they are
creating and displaying is one that they
feel like taking off at the end of the
day
drag didn't used to be confused about
this
but Barbie the movie seems perfectly
happy to add the confusion in Barbie
land woman is a costume to begin with
upon arriving at a meeting of Mattel
executive stereotypical Barbie despairs
of the lack of women in the c-suite I'm
a man with no power offers the internet
attendance does that make me a woman
well no Aaron it does not
in both the dragon Barbie Confections
the focus is on Surface appearances and
Illusions the clothes the makeup the
hair in Barbie land many other things
become fashion accessory as well the
house the job the man and in both
Womanhood itself is a costume something
to be taken on and off at will one of
the Barbies in the film is played by a
trans woman and so the farce is complete
I got the role because I fit the role
explains hard enough to be honest I
don't look much different in the movie
than the Barbies that I had when I was a
kid
Barbie is an impossible fantasy
her phenotype obtainable only through a
combination of obsessive focus on how
you look and plastic surgery
at least with drag
you don't need the surgery
yeah I'm reminded I mean this the whole
world is so polluted by advertising but
I'm reminded of a dove
campaign from years ago in which they
actually
showed what it took to take a model and
turn her into the thing that one sees in
an advertisement and the answer was it
actually is physically beyond the
capacity of an earth woman to be what is
often presented in advertising and it
requires Photoshop and the stretching of
next and the reproportioning of things
to take even an attractive woman and uh
you know an arms race has has unfolded
and the problem
you know somewhere next up anime
right somewhere long stretch bits and I
mean right as soon as as soon as it's an
avatar and the point is well what are
you really into it doesn't have to be
connected to reality right right so are
you like that you want to wear that we
can give you more of that now again the
connection to uh Market forces is very
troubling to me but the idea that Ivory
girl was a Trope that was resonant
enough that anybody our age knows what
that means right the girl next door that
these were things that were understood
not to be in conflict with beauty right
this was a reduction in dedication to
artificial Beauty and an emphasis on
natural beauty and unfortunately in the
world trap between the two gutters of
RuPaul's Drag Race and Barbie land
what's lost is
a future in which women are not hobbled
for our hours a day making sure they
looked just so but they can in fact be
human and do what humans do and it not
be thought ugly
okay one more section um but before we
go there I will say that I'm I'm not
reading a lot of this including
my analysis of the really unfortunate
depiction of the relationships between
the sexes in Barbie land
um the the stuff between the Barbies and
the Kens is um kind of diabolical
actually uh so uh please please go and
and read that here but I feel like we've
gone and we've diabolical and it is the
thing uh that I believe is most
inconsistent with the idea that Barbie
land is in some sense the conservative
gutter
right the depiction of the relation
between the Sexes as I understand it
from you I haven't seen the film but uh
is uh much more of the postmodern
anything goes left then no no no not at
all it's it's a it's it's either men
rule or women rule and you can keep
having men and women fight over who's
who it's going to be go Barbie land
Kingdom Barbie land
um but you what you cannot absolutely
cannot have is both sexes actually um
having power at the same time but isn't
it uh uh anti-monogamy doesn't it
yes but that is not what you were just
talking about no it is I mean uh anyway
it's
yes there's that I don't think you quite
have it right because I think that this
piece this is it feels very much like a
unfortunate
it's like it's it's the stupid left
response to the stupid right where the
stupid right is like men just need to be
in charge 100 of the time all the time
you see what happens when you let women
start to get in charge then the stupid
left is going like oh well maybe Barbie
was possible after all maybe we can have
a world in which there aren't even any
male Supreme Court Justices and like
those are our two options since when are
those are two options anyway I mean I
could read that part but let me let me I
think I'm not going to I'm just going to
read one more section here you can go
ahead and show my screen and just
another little still from the RuPaul's
Drag Race
um here we have
um Asia the host with
um they're back to the camera
attractive tall
curvy and uh I have no idea how to
pronounce this Deja Sky maybe
um the other fan favorite
um
another absurd looking sort of
caricature of I don't know the Disney
princess I don't even know what
costume changes are a large part of both
shows of course not just between acts
but during acts It's Magic meets fashion
trusting your eyes and watching them
fail you is again and again something
new shows up underneath what you thought
was the base layer humans as onions the
metaphor revealed through fashion
in work the world occasional big black
conical breastplates are reminiscent of
1980s Madonna The Bouncing rolls of fat
most definitely are not everything is
sexual some of the sex is violent
the misogyny is sometimes Stark the word
[__] always spelled out rather than said
as a word is spat out several times why
why does one drag queen ask another to
look at your c-u-n-t is it disturbing
just for the sake of being disturbing is
this a dare
we're not telling someone else to look
at the genitalia they patently do not
have the drag queens are all about
bringing the attention back to
themselves look at me while I do nothing
of note look at me while I work it look
at me look at me look at me
there are fantasy in Hollywood and
Disney references throughout both of
these concoctions oddly The Matrix is
invoked in both
on offer red pill to wake up and have a
challenging of difficult life or blue
pill to retain comfort and cluelessness
Barbie as you would expect wants the
blue pill she wants her high-heeled feet
back after they've gone flat on her and
for everything to go back to normal
but she doesn't get what she wants and
she's better for it red pill for the win
work the world is constructed to reveal
the hive mind of the audience and time
and again the audience says it wants the
red pill
they are certain that they would choose
to wake up to reality as ugly and
uncomfortable as that might be
this may be the most surprising part of
the night for me
here is an audience so unmatched in a
fantasy Escape that they are convinced
not only that they are interested in
being awake and in choosing reality over
short-term Pleasures but that they have
already awoken to reality
this feels like it may be a a critical
key and the most important thing here
that
yeah I was surprised I mean there's a
lot of cultural references
presumably that I didn't get in RuPaul's
Drag Race but many that I did and and
many many and Barbie from from Hollywood
history from film history many of which
I think I did get
um and that's that's fun that's good but
the fact that the Matrix shows up in
both places is fascinating and that it
shows up in these
Confections these concoctions that are
so that are presenting a vision of the
world that is so dystopian and so
farcical and so awful
and that in one of the cases the
audience has an ability to reveal what
it is that they would choose if offered
the choice on The Matrix of the red pill
versus the blue pill and the audience
makes it clear that they think they've
been repelled
I don't like it's amazing well I mean
this is going to
link us into the next and that's the
part of it but the I I I'm in a losing
battle
for a very long period of time over the
resurrection of the idea of red pill it
is such an important idea that the fact
that we are losing it to Andrew Tate and
RuPaul and whoever else and Barbie
is
uh it's a huge loss because and you know
as we've talked about uh previously
The Matrix is effectively Plato's Cave
right remade in a modern form and
Plato's Cave is a story that has to be
represented regularly in order for
people to understand the possibility of
being
beguiled by a fiction
um and there is a reality to be
understood I mean Plato's Cave the
essential feature of it is that the
person who has seen the outside world is
not welcomed by is uh compatriots in the
cave he is killed right the idea of an
outside world that is actually real is
so troubling that uh he has ended and
we need this concept of red pill and it
does not belong to conservatives it does
not belong to any of the constituencies
that would adopt it it is not theirs it
is our common property and I will say
that the fact of the machowski brothers
now sisters having produced The Matrix
having given us the red pill and now
having confused the matter is uh you
know it's like a knife to the heart
right yeah and
um I don't know what we do about it I
guess we'll begin transition yeah
I mean
I don't know
produced in water I I don't I'd
forgotten that so maybe that it
partially explains why it ends up but
yeah it may be why it ends up there
um and then the the Andrew Tate version
of this is so troubling also
um
and because Andrew you know Andrew Tate
is
also not incorrect about a lot of what
he observes about the world but he is
apparently based on a tremendous amount
of video that I've now seen of him
saying in his own words you know
instructing men how to view women and
it's this it is this parasitic view of
women that they must be dominated they
must be abused
um that this is the natural order of
things and it's just a it's a horrifying
uh way of looking at it so to have him
using red pill as his you know Central
uh his Central metaphor is just very
very destructive
so look
we are living in something shockingly
matrix-like and
we do need
people red pilled and you know there's a
lot of nuance that isn't in there I I
find myself talking to other people who
see the world as we do and saying don't
forget the most any of us is is half
awake right it's not that we've been red
building we see the world we don't yet
know what we don't yet know and you and
I keep discovering this you know as much
as we are aware of all sorts of uh
malfeasance and skullduggery we keep
discovering stuff that we didn't miss
because we didn't see because you can't
pay attention to it all at the same time
um so anyway it's it's the red pill
moment and of course if it's the red
pill moment and you are an entity that
is protected by the blue pill then
trivializing the Red Pill by putting it
in Barbie's mouth or you know RuPaul's
and everybody embracing it because
they're the you know the cognizant uh
will turn it into nothing
it makes the metaphor useless and it
means that we now are again you know
grasping for for some some way to convey
to people you haven't seen it yet
because you're still inside the cave
looking at the Shadows on the wall
yeah
um
the the scene in Barbie
where uh
stereotypical Barbies morose and doesn't
know how to
get her world back
um and her her feet have literally
fallen so instead of walking around like
this she's she's got flat feet for the
first time you know Barbie dolls
actually have the high heel feet you
know this
so I guess they would have to but right
so um it's it's
there's a suspension of disbelief that
you can do to watch a good part of this
movie and just be entertained right and
um and the acting is great and the you
know the production values incredibly
High all of this
um but so her she steps out of her shoes
and her feet are still shaped like
high-heeled yeah and and
um and then one day they collapse and
she's horrified and she shows the other
Barbies they're like oh my God that's
hideous what is wrong with your feet
right
so she ends up several scenes later I
think
um in front of weird Barbie uh you know
with the cut off hair and the marker on
her face uh and weird Barbie is like
you're gonna have to go out into the
real world babe like you're gonna have
to just go out and find the girl who is
like putting thoughts of death in your
in your head and like flattening your
feet
um but weird Barbie comes at her with
like you can have the Stiletto
or the Birkenstock
and Barbie's like I want the Stiletto I
definitely want the Stiletto and weird
Barbies like no sorry that wasn't
actually a choice you're being red
pilled girl so like what it works right
like there's pieces in here that are
actually like I I just it's not okay to
be spoofing things and then keep your
options open and also be in in the woke
world or in what like it's not a spoof
if you've kept all of your options open
and when the audience decides what it
thinks and what it wants then you're
like yeah that's what I meant right like
as the filmmaker as the actors and
actresses as as the people who put this
together you have to actually have a
position that you stand by because the
fact that I can see some goodness here
I'm not I don't want to trust that
because they the filmmakers haven't
earned
the my trust sufficiently to be sure
that that scene right there is actually
more evocative of what they were trying
to do than the bit where
um the Ken's are mocked for actually
caring about the Barbies so it is
we've all met the girl or young woman
who uses the idea that she was kidding
to cover if she says something to see
what reaction it gets and the reaction
isn't good then it was kidding yeah
right and so that is cheating that is
cheating that is cheating it's
absolutely cheating you don't get to
keep all of your options open right you
don't get to be like I want to do this
I'm going to do this I'm going to try
out this oh you like that yeah I'm gonna
bury that [__] right and and just keep
pushing forward with the thing like I
was just doing trial balloons like yeah
but at the time you came across as if
you had a position and it turns out you
didn't
this was audience generated conclusion
as opposed to you have come to an idea
and you put that idea in a creative form
in front of us so it strikes me that the
the missing thing
um in the dichotomy between the Stiletto
at the Birkenstock uh is
um the sensible shoes of course and I my
as you know personally I find high heels
uh detract
from attractiveness because they suggest
a willingness to self-hobble which I
don't find attractive yeah there was an
event we were going to a while back uh
and I was like I think I guess I'm fancy
of that I think I need to get some heels
you're like no no well like let's let's
find some really nice boots yes yeah
right exactly I'm not against you know
something sexy but yeah uh unless anyone
get some stupid idea about what that was
I was like oh thank God okay I don't
have it real good right but you know if
the sensible Shoe Fits wear it right and
that's the missing thing you know the
ivory girl girl next door sensible shoes
the point is
why and you know frankly let's just go
there
all right where we going same issue with
huge boobs
they're hobbling and it's one thing in
some cases that's a choice but generally
I mean it wasn't until recently huge
boobs is in general a choice
um some women have huge boobs yep that
is true but I guess my point is for you
know
they are hobbling because they are
mechanistically for something and the
fact that they are mechanistically for
something and have become an
advertisement of fertility and therefore
men are focused on them which causes
women in an arms race to go to surgeons
to augment these things the point is
actually again you're self-hobbling yeah
I'm sure that's the you know
I don't know maybe I'm alone in this but
it's not attractive to self-hobble right
right I mean I guess you know
given who I ended up with uh an enabled
woman is obviously uh my type but a
self-hobbling woman you know maybe you
have to for your role in the world but
if you don't it just it just seems like
an advertisement that you're not
interested in accomplishing things at
least in certain Realms right no I mean
it's and this this does play into the
um generally conservative you know Trad
tropes of uh you know this these these
are your years honey like between the
ages of 16 and 24 or whatever like
that's that's when you got to do it so
play it for all you got because you're
not gonna be worth anything later yeah
and so you know to to the women who are
playing into that I would say you do
hope to live past 24 don't you like well
you do do you expect to be on this
planet for a good long time and it's one
thing to be to be beautiful and to say
you know what I'm beautiful but it's
quite another to say that's the only
thing that I'm going to invest in it's
like you know it's like we've said to
our boys like what you don't want is for
high school to be the best part of your
life
right like you you always want to be
able to look ahead and say I'm still
trying to get somewhere I'm still
aspiring to something
it strikes me
the tragedy
um for women in an age in which
achievement is
more possible than it has ever been
where access has been uh opened up to
the the greatest extent is that women
have two kinds of
potential power one of them is
the result of physical attractiveness it
eeks very very young and then degrades
and so that idea of like well if you're
going to capitalize now is the time is
about this kind of power which is always
coupled with somebody too young to know
what to do with power inherently right
inherently whereas the other kind of
power for women comes through
achievement and insight and that of
course as with men is going to grow over
time as you come to understand the world
better come to accumulate skills and all
of this and the sexual Obsession of
Western Civilization has caused one of
these things to be emphasized as female
power and the other one to be uh ignored
and marginalized and the two of them to
be mixed so that you know we will
actually do Insane things like uh you
know critique the looks of a highly
achieving woman you know
as a primary consideration
um so anyway the point is that that
Trope about you better get on it is
really about like a
scholarship is the wrong word because
scholarship is about learning but the
idea that they're for a beautiful woman
there is a way to get a free ride
through life and it involves
capitalizing on that female Beauty early
in life as it Peaks and finding someone
who will carry you through to the Finish
Line
um and that's not really what anybody
should be telling women because there's
this whole other thing which is really
about you know okay you're a human being
you've got a lifetime what can you
achieve
right yeah that's really what we should
be emphasizing that's right
um well you've been at this for a while
yes so um I know you have a lot that you
want to talk about
I will try to be efficient about it well
I'm just uh I'm I'm just trying to hand
the
Sharpie over to you thank you
[Laughter]
um yes I did but now he knows he has it
you have the talking Sharpie I have the
talking Sharpie all right uh what I want
to talk about is something I didn't get
to uh last live stream which is
something I've noticed about the term
deep state which is a term that I find
tremendously important right up there
with something like red pill and what I
noticed was starting in about somewhere
in the neighborhood of 2016.
that the term I understood which I don't
know when I learned the term deep state
but probably in college yeah
that the term that I know was suddenly
being supplanted by a definition that
not only did I not recognize it as uh
correct but that was actually
destructive of our ability to talk about
the Deep state which I believe that we
have to and this had a lot when it
happened in 2016 it had a lot to do with
Trump of course because Trump was all
about talking about the Deep state and
its effect and mind you the Deep state
is a hypothesis
I think it's a very strong hypothesis
but it is a hypothesis by its very
nature it is not something that we can
investigate and establish its existence
we have to infer its existence from the
way history proceeds and one of the
features of the deep state is that it
obscures itself so it it's a troubling
problem but as soon as Trump started
you're going to tell us what the
hypothesis is well I'm going to tell you
what the two styles of different
hypotheses
um
well that's a great question I would say
one of them is a hypothesis and the
other has the same status except that it
is so certain to be true that it's
effectively a tautology okay so what
excuse me what you started hearing about
in the late 80s early 90s
um is what was known as The Deep state
is a hypothesis and uh the the newer
Incarnation
um yeah maybe so but in a trivial way
because it must be true it can't help
but
let us talk about the let's let's start
with the second one first because the
I'm I'm going to argue that this is an
illegitimate use of the term and we need
some other term for it and this is and
mind you many of the people that we like
a great deal people we think highly of
their capacity to think have embraced a
definition like this and the definition
is essentially
the you you have a state the United
States and the United States is
ostensibly governed by Democratic
processes in which we elect and unelect
People based on our sense that they will
do our bidding once in power but there
is a vast bureaucracy under them and you
can't swap it out every time
administrations change so the point is
there's a huge number of people who
remain in their position in the state
department because they know how to do
that thing and you can't start from
scratch every time you switch
administrations so that vast
bureaucratic bureaucratic network of
people
the term the first time I heard this
abused the point was these are the
people who keep the likes on
right that thing has power because it is
composed of people those people have
beliefs about what should be true what
shouldn't be true and you can imagine
that that vast bureaucracy if it were
for example unhappy with a person or an
Administration that had just been
elected could drag its heels and engage
in bits of sabotage here and there and
that that the amount of power in that
vast bureaucratic Network that cannot be
replaced is
um considerable and as a force of
history that we cannot speak to directly
because it's an emergent property
okay so that's the in my opinion broken
definition
the correct definition the broken
definition the new definition
sure but it must be true and so it's not
that interesting to talk about as if
it's surprising right it has to be true
and
I'm not sure I understand the question
but I won't
um so anyway I say it's a a tautology
because although we can't
calibrate how big a force of History it
could be it could be a huge force of
History this bureaucratic uh inertia or
it could be a minor force of History it
could be anywhere in between
um
that it is some force of history is
essentially certain so it is a
hypothesis but it is so close to being
certain that we don't have to treat it
as uh highly speculative
um
the correct definition I believe and I
now know from doing some research into
the history of the term is quite
different it is effectively a cabal that
exists behind the scenes uh inside of
the governance structure which doesn't
have to mean the official governance
structure maybe not employed by the
government right and in fact it will
undoubtedly have roles inside of
official government it will have roles
outside of official government and it
takes a position on policy
but we cannot vote against it we cannot
evaluate it we cannot and this is I
think the sin Quan on apparently it is
inherently a shadowy force it does not
abide to the consent of the governed we
didn't decide to put it in power it is
therefore a violation of the most sacred
principle that's true of both
yes and no it's not really true of the
bureaucracy because the bureaucracy
didn't elect itself we elected people
they decided how to put the bureaucracy
together and their control over it may
be less effective than we would like but
it's not that any of the people in the
bureaucracy can't be fired they can all
be fired right the how do you fire the
Deep State you can't and I want to point
to the thing that I I would call the
city they don't have official jobs right
it's not an official entity it doesn't
have a name it doesn't have an office
um so the point is yes there are people
in the Deep State who are undoubtedly in
positions from which they could be fired
but you can't fire the Deep State why
can't you fire the Deep State here's the
sin Quan on the central element okay the
thing that makes it the Deep state is a
black budget
what does that mean a black budget is a
budget that is acquired through
extra
legal extra constitutional means
so let's just say the CIA
has a budget that budget comes through
the Congress the Congress has the power
of the purse and the Congress could in
theory decide to cut off the CIA however
we do know that for example the Once
Upon a Time outlandish conspiracy theory
that the CIA was trafficking drugs into
the United States turns out to be well
supported by evidence what do they do
with those drugs
well here's the thing if you're if you
are a an entity that has uh powers to
cross borders to engage in crime frankly
in order to do your job right you can't
you know so the CIA has vast powers to
act uh outside of the law ostensibly it
is supposed to be acting outside of the
United States but nonetheless it has
great powers that have been granted to
it by the state and if it uses those
powers
to generate funds that are not on the
books then the point is nobody can take
those funds away and so nor do they need
to be explained right neither can they
disappear until they're spent
um but nor do they need to be spent on
anything that is gone through any sort
of process and vetting right so what I
want to lay out is a model
where
why the Deep State seems to have come
into existence and what it might mean
that it seems to exist again it's a
hypothesis but it's one that I believe
is is well supported by evidence
did you sorry did you run into when does
when does the term emerge do you know
ah the term you were hearing it in the
late 80s I was hearing it in the late
80s and then in doing some research uh I
discovered some things I did not know
about the history of the term there are
insects on your paper there are insects
on my paper
I don't know there's nothing to do with
the Deep State yeah uh all right so the
source here is a site called thoughtco
which I did not know uh yeah you want to
show it and then um uh hit and miss it's
it's not it's Hit or Miss it's not
perfect but I think people can check
whether or not they've done their
homework properly but I think what I'm
going to read is uh
I I mean if they didn't make it up
entirely which they won't have uh it
it's a good first pass
um the concept of the deep State also
called a state within a state or a
shadow government was first used in
reference to political conditions in
countries like turkey and post-soviet
Russia during the 50s an influential
anti-democratic Coalition within the
Turkish political system called the
Darren devlet literally the Deep State
allegedly dedicated itself to ousting
Communists from the Turkish Republic
founded by Mustafa Ataturk after World
War One made up of elements within the
Turkish military security Judiciary
Judiciary branches
the darylan devlet worked to turn the
Turkish people against its enemies that
is the enemies of the deep state by
staging false flag attacks and planned
riots ultimately the Darren devil it was
blamed for the deaths of thousands of
people
so wow that origin that's long after
Ataturk but in ataturk's Turkey yeah
um so
a
the Deep state if that is indeed the
origin of the term matches what I'm
calling the well supported by evidence
hypothesis of a cabal that seeks to
wield power in spite of not having been
elected and not the vast bureaucracy
that keeps the lights on but probably
also has a political perspective that in
some way affects the way government
governance occurs right
um
okay
how does such a thing happen well first
I want to uh I don't like doing this but
I think it needs to be done I want
to point out that there are processes
which to an honest uh broker inside of
the intelligence Community inside of
the establishment in many places are
absolutely frightening right processes
like democracy right democracy I mean
you know the founders of the U.S were
terrified by the ability of the mob to
do rash things and they worried about
this in creating a Democratic Republic
they worried about the tyranny of the
majority in particular so democracy is
understood to be a dangerous phenomenon
because you can't predict what it's
going to do and so you can certainly
imagine that somebody even somebody who
ostensibly was public-minded who was
interested in protecting the citizenry
might rightly fear that the people could
go nuts and do some bad stuff and so
democracy is a kind of a scary principle
to
um to establish because what will you do
if it doesn't go well
um likewise science right science
scientists are annoying people they can
come up with stuff yeah but I mean from
the point of view of folks who are just
trying to get stuff done the idea that
science can decide that you know what
you've been doing in the world is
actually dangerous to the public right
what do you do if you create an industry
and uh you know it's all going
swimmingly and then suddenly somebody
pipes up and says hey by the way that
process that you're engaged in is
causing all of these harms right that's
a that's a frightening risk to take
journalists oh my God you think
scientists are annoying these people are
incredible they just don't stop they're
always digging into stuff they're always
looking for dirt on people and lo and
behold you can find that whatever you
did to make your business happen is
suddenly on the front page of the New
York Times right so that's a scary
process
Regulators right Regulators could uh
take some you know 100 million dollar
research project of yours that was
targeted on finding some uh beautiful
drug that was going to cure some disease
and they could decide that
um you know it's not safe to give to
enough people to make it profitable it's
gonna be Downstream and science
hopefully
one would hope right so anyway my point
is there are lots of frightening
processes out there that people who are
interested in doing whatever it is that
they are targeted on could understand
the belief here right democracy
journalism science Regulators they could
fear being taxed into Oblivion they
could now in the modern era they could
fear uh social media influencers right
yes I mean what happens if somebody
starts broadcasting inconvenient truths
from their man cave about your safe and
effective vaccines for example right
that could be a problem
Spider-Man cave I wasn't talking about
us
um I was talking about someone else's
man cave but anyway point is look
you can imagine that people who are
trying to do stuff in the market might
have understandable fears about what
process could come out of nowhere and
upend whatever it is they've invested in
and they might think what can we do to
hedge out that risk right yep so
that I believe is going to be the origin
of this deep State impulse which is not
fundamentally American we see it in the
context of you know turkey and
post-soviet Russia give out what you
just said it's probably the time to
mention that Rumble has collapsed so
we're still on YouTube and you should
keep going but
apparently in fact the whole site
actually it was just us for a little bit
and I collapsed huh all right well
Rumble has apparently collapsed that is
interesting seriously I wasn't given
that you given what you were talking
about I figured it was worth mentioning
like breaking news is it still working
uh the chat's still up on locals um but
people have to watch on YouTube right
now
wow well we're recording it all we'll go
we're listening and and more people do
listen afterwards than than watch
um this should concern you not at all
but that's rather remarkable I've never
seen Rumble Rumble has learned it
doesn't tend to collapse yeah um well in
any case what else is there to do but
for see the strangest things can leap up
and get in the road of what you're
trying to accomplish
um yeah they don't seem that strange
anymore yeah they don't seem that
strange anymore yeah now let's talk
about what it means if we dichotomize
the concept of deep State and mind you I
have a uh
lexicographical rule is that a word I
don't know I don't Mexico gravel yeah I
have a word about
lexicon
okay it's just a part of the
lexicological lexicological I don't
think that's right well what's that
all right that was uh that was your
mother that was a team effort yeah um
okay
the rule is this
first of all the reason for the rule is
the following thing when you do
independent work
when you think independently about some
Realm
you end up having to redefine terms it
is required because if we use the
definitions of terms that are generally
available they all have become blunt
because people use them in many
different ways and so every term is a
blunt instrument and in order to do
logical work properly you have to
sharpen the terms so that they mean
something very precise and most people
who do this forget that they've
redefined them and then when they talk
to each other they sound like idiots
they are unable to converse so my rules
on interacting
with people who have likely redefined
terms for their own purposes is look I
don't care if we use my definition or
your definition but I care that every
single term we need is precisely defined
and that there is a term for every
single thing we need to talk about
um and we start by trying to establish a
dictionary right and it takes weeks
often to learn to understand some what
somebody means by the words that they're
using so you know or just you I guess I
haven't seen you try to establish a
dictionary so much as be insistent on
stopping whenever a word is used that
might have any complexity to it at all
and being like okay you use that word
and and rather than sort of Princess
Bride style like I don't think you know
what that word means like how are you
using that what do you think it means
what what are you what do you and so in
this case I'm going to say that the
evidence of the term deep State actually
comes from turkey and that it means
something close to what I think the Deep
State means is a case in which that that
definition should Prevail and the vast
bureaucratic inertia that prevents
things from changing as fast as uh The
Ballot Box would have it change
um bureaucratic inertia sounds pretty
good fast bureaucratic inertia something
it needs determine maybe that's a decent
one
um
but okay so the sin Quan on just as the
sin quanon of fascism is the fusion of
corporate power and government power the
sin quanon of the deep state is the
existence of a black budget that allows
it to remain even when attempts to
control it are imposed and allows it to
continue over time
um uh without us being able to assess
what it's done because we can't look at
what it spent yeah uh okay so to me
this question let's talk again in the
realm of hypothesis
we have a battle
that never resolves over what took place
in 1963 in the United States in Delhi
Plaza
a president was assassinated
nobody disputes this but what the
meaning of that assassination was we are
battling over it even if we don't
realize it right there is a battle over
the narrow question did Oswald act alone
or was there some group involved in that
assassination but what we don't
typically talk about
is the implication of that branch in the
decision tree
if Oswald acted alone
then it wasn't a coup because Oswald
died days later at the hand of Jack Ruby
right so he wouldn't have taken power
anyway but he certainly didn't take
power because he died so he did not
commit an assassination to take power on
the other hand if something else
assassinated Kennedy then there is at
least the possibility
that there was a coup that something
killed him in order to take power and if
that did happen then the question is
what happened to it does it still have
power did it lose power in a later
election we don't know and we can't ask
the question in a standard sense because
it doesn't exist on the books
well and did it lose power in a later
election
that question suggests that
um
that it would inherently that some
elections might cause a deep State
entity to lose power and I don't I don't
think it would be that clean
well so again we are now in the realm of
speculation yeah and and
there's so many lovers you know there's
some struck there's some structure
hypothetically
which is unknown to us unseen by us uh
and uh the nature of the hierarchy
within that structure is totally
unperceived so what would cause it
to lose power change power
um come to want a different thing
well you know let's put it this way an
overt coup
a military
uh regimen goes Rogue
which we don't see here we don't yeah
it's not it's not an American style
modern Africa sure yeah so some Junta
takes over they rule for a bit and then
some process happens and the Hunt is no
longer in power
um
I'm trying to remember exactly what the
origin story for the sandinistas who
were briefly in power in Nicaragua was
but the yeah actually and some some
Modern stories from Latin America too is
a little bit so a little a little bit
Loosely speaking but Loosely speaking at
the sandinistas defeated the Samosa
regime in Nicaragua they ruled for a bit
and were
uh displaced by the Uno party I believe
yeah tomorrow right which with the help
of the CIA
uh right
exactly so in uh 1980s
sometime late 80s yeah
so okay so that would be the way that
something that had engaged in a coup
could lose power later and there was a
weird power sharing arrangement in
Nicaragua where the sandinistas actually
remained in charge of the military uh in
the aftermath of the tomorrow
Administration taking power so anyway it
was an interesting interesting story but
you know such things are not you know
Nicaragua still exists
um although I mean just as an aside when
we were there in 1991
uh the uh totally justified
anti-American sentiment was uh intense
and we had we traveled through all of
the countries of Central America except
for Belize and El Salvador in that trip
and only in Nicaragua did we feel like
we are clearly not welcome here and we
understand why and we're not going to
spend a lot of time
so
1963 yeah
was that an assassination with no coup
or was that a coup that we couldn't see
because we didn't understand what had
taken place and I will say you know oh
my God wild eyed conspiracy theory Well
turns out
that according to the site uh 538 Nate
Silver's statistical site uh only 33 of
Americans and this is a relatively
recent survey only 33 percent of
Americans believe that Oswald acted
alone
um so
the idea that there was some sort of a
conspiracy that involved Oswald Plus at
least one other person uh is widely
shared yeah and for good reason if you
look at the evidence surrounding the
Kennedy assassination it is just like
the ballistics
how could Oswald shooting from where he
was shooting have accomplished what he
did accomplish it is not a easily
answered question in fact it's kind of
an unanswerable question I would also
say there is you know just to take one
example if you look at
um Dan Rather who was given the
exclusive right to view the Zapruder
film the recruiter film which we I think
all kind of intuitively feel has been
around since the assassination but was
actually held privately until relatively
recently Dan Rather reports exactly
incorrectly what he saw on that film
exactly incorrectly yes about the
e-reports exactly and correctly about
the trajectory of the president's head
in the aftermath which suggests that the
bullet came from the depository which is
not what's reflected on the actual
supporter film
and so just to understand the semantics
thing of what you're saying Dan Rather
was given the exclusive right to talk
about this operator film what he says in
his public report is exactly incorrect
if you look at the Pruder film and you
look at what Dan Rather said about the
supporter film they are exactly so he is
asked a public comment it's a comment
publicly on the saprita film before
anyone in the public can see it right
and he makes comments that once the
Supreme film is in the public realm
which it is now you can see is exactly
the opposite of what is actually
happening exactly exactly and so it what
rather said supports the idea that the
shot came from The Book Depository
behind the precedent and what is on the
film does not but anyway so there's lots
of strange evidence and then there's the
strangest piece of evidence of all from
the John Kennedy assassination which is
the Robert Kennedy senior assassination
if there was a coup in 1963 did it
protect itself in 1968 by eliminating
Robert Kennedy senior
so anyway there's good reason for
Americans to wonder whether or not
something took control and refused to
relinquish it and that this is you know
if that didn't happen then our history
looks like one thing and if we've been
living under a regime that is not
elected and decided to take power and
not relinquish it our history means
something entirely different for 60
years well you know I don't think Trump
is part of it I think somehow Trump
actually got himself elected and if that
was in spite of the fact that a deep
State existed and didn't want him uh to
ascend to the office then he outfoxed it
um which is pretty interesting and it
would explain a lot of what has happened
in the aftermath right that oh my God
the Deep state has lost its power but of
course because it's a deep State and the
fact that a president is antagonistic to
it doesn't mean that the president could
shut it down because it doesn't have a
phone number right
um so anyway that would explain a lot of
of what we've seen there and in any case
it's just simply something that we need
to wrap our minds around our history
could mean one of two things depending
upon what happened in 1963 and we don't
know
um so that is that is a profound
challenge it requires us to clarify our
thinking around what the term deep State
actually
um means and
I guess I would connect it
to one other thread an important
uh thread that has bubbled up in the com
in the public conversation of late
which has to do with
Biden family corruption specifically
surrounding Hunter and you know the
defense that has always been made is
well that's Hunter that's not Joe but
much of what Hunter says suggest Joe is
involved and in fact there's evidence
this week that uh Hunter put Joe on the
phone uh
in any case there is the terrible stench
of
um
influence influence peddling with
impunity by the bidens now this is
slightly galling to me because I was
trying to call attention to that fact
before Joe Biden was elected president
I don't know how many times between uh
my Twitter account between interviews in
various places Dark Horse uh or um what
was it called the campfires that Unity
2020 held the idea that the DNC was an
influence pedaling racket that
uh Joe Biden was a clear career
influence Peddler that this put the
country in great danger these were
things in which I was trying to raise
the alarm before we ever elected this
guy precedent right and the fact that we
are now finally seeing tons and tons of
evidence I mean okay the evidence is
interesting but how could anybody be
shocked by this this was obvious that
this is uh what the man was and as his
decrepitude has advanced
the failure of the blue team to react
like this is in any way important
actually suggests that they understand
that the president is not really in
power it doesn't matter that he's
decrepit because something else controls
the way the country functions in the
first place and so
I'm not sure what to do with all of that
but we do seem to be stuck in a place
where something appears to be
controlling our trajectory
we have elections but elections are not
the same thing as democracy
and we are now faced with
an appalling level of control over what
we can discuss we are now watching
people uh until Marcola had his bank
accounts suspended
um for without explanation by Chase Bank
um this is he he reports Dr Mercola yeah
yeah uh he he recall he reports that
this has happened and you know between
the insane overreach punishing people
who
um speak out of turn the IRS showing up
at Matt taibi's Door uh in the immediate
aftermath of uh Twitter files
Revelations
the number of
uh off-brand forms of control and
coercion that are being used to prevent
those who would still engage in
journalism those who would uh engage in
science in science those who would
engage in medicine any of these things
it's obvious that it's happening and
what the connection between all these
things is admittedly I don't know
but it's obvious that we should be
asking the question especially you know
in light of what we have discovered
about for example the five eyes Alliance
which is an alliance between the United
States the UK New Zealand Canada and
Australia that effectively functions to
allow
states to Outsource violations of its
own citizens rights by having the
intelligence agencies of other countries
do the spying God other than uh the fact
that it's missing Canada that's the
greatest hits of bad covet response
countries
he does have camera
UK the U.S Canada Australia New Zealand
Australia that's crazy yeah that's like
that's the greatest hits right there
that's the greatest hits right and
actually uh so anyway the point is what
is that thing well you know
um intelligence agencies you know the
the FBI is limited by the Constitution
the CIA is not limited by the
Constitution because it's ostensibly
supposed to be pointed outwards outside
of the United States
um but you know you can trade
effectively you can have somebody else
spy on your citizens in a way you're not
technically allowed to and if everybody
pulls those resources basically the
Constitutional protections don't exist
but it sounds like you're opposed to
convenience
well
okay we're gonna add convenience to
Recreation as things that I alone am
opposed to but
um all right I'm gonna get off I've been
you grad that it makes it easier for
them
yeah it's an efficiency thing it saves
money off their black budgets so they
can right yeah all right um I think that
that's more or less what I wanted to
outline we will we will oh no there was
one other thing I wanted to add
um is that 48 Point font
I'm sorry I'm stuck permanently I don't
need glasses for distance I do need them
for reading and if I'm not going to be
constantly putting them on uh I need to
have large fonts so I make no apology I
know I wouldn't have said that if I
thought you were embarrassed by it yeah
all right so here's the final thing I
want to point out
we have a terrible corruption problem
right those of us who have thought
deeply about it call It capture for a
reason because it's not a an adjustment
to policy based on a certain amount of
resources flowing in the wrong direction
it is actually the commandeering of
agencies and institutions and the
repurposing of them offered in the exact
inverse direction that they are supposed
to be pointed
okay so that's a terrible problem
we've now seen it during covid not only
did we do everything wrong but we did
everything the opposite of right right
something was very interested in Pharma
coming out of that uh you know glowing
and uh it didn't really care that people
were going to get maimed in the process
all right that's a terrible corruption
problem
does anybody think
the fact that we have a pay for play
political system has not been noticed by
our enemies
why would our enemies not have noticed
that in the United States if you have
enough resources you can get policy that
fits your special interest and if your
special interest is that you're an enemy
of the US and you want us for example
um to I don't know feminize our military
or something so they're less scary uh
that there's probably a price
right given Biden family corruption I
think we have to ask the question why
are we fighting a proxy war
in Ukraine why are we risking nuclear
war in Ukraine is that because somebody
thinks this is a good idea for the
American public or is it because
something external has paid the price to
get us to do it I don't know the answer
to that question I don't pretend to but
I do think it is a question we have to
ask and I would I in thinking about how
to present this I remembered
as you know one of my favorite uh
fiction books is Catch 22.
and I was reminded of a particular
episode in Catch-22 almost all of the
episodes in Catch-22 have been uh have
happened in real life in a much less
comedic form yes in the years since I've
been aware of it but I was reminded of
uh a particular episode in Catch-22
surrounding
Milo minder binder and for those who
haven't read the book I just want to say
Milo minder binder I think is the most
interesting character in the whole book
Milo minderbinder starts out as a
likable uh ambitious
patriot who attempts to do his job he is
in charge of the commissary I guess
providing food oh just food uh yeah I
think I think he's providing food for
the pilots In This World War II Air
Force Base
and Milo uh initially provides wonderful
food because if he's going to provide
food why wouldn't he provide the best
and so he does a spectacular job and
this brings him in contact with the
market right because of course you have
to Source the ingredients to make the
marvelous food for the pilots and so
anyway he uh at first makes normal
contact with Market forces and as the
book progresses those Market forces turn
him from this likable uh you know
ambitious guy with plenty of pluck and
Ingenuity but
underlying pages into a
hitlerian character right
um seamlessly and so in one case uh
which I uh
I managed to find the text of
um Milo who has produced something
called The Syndicate The Syndicate does
the trading that allows him to procure
the supplies but it becomes this
business
um so in one of his you know in an early
uh episode with the Syndicate The
Syndicate
um has purchased a huge amount of
Egyptian cotton which turns out to have
been a terrible you can't unload the
stuff he can't trade it he's just got
warehouses full of stuff he wants to get
rid of it and so he decides to try to
feed it to the pilots and of course it's
yeah inedible so it didn't work but
anyway that's mild compared to what goes
on later later in the book uh there's a
a case where nately one of the pilots
has died because he's bailed out of his
plane and his parachute has been
replaced by shares in The Syndicate
which he discovers
if he pulls the rip cord and
Milo has a conversation with yosarian
about the fact of Nate Lee's untimely
death
Milo says nightly died a wealthy
manuserian he had over 60 shares in The
Syndicate because Aryan says what
difference does that make he's dead
minderbinder says well then his family
will get it you know sarian says he
didn't have time to have a family
Milo says then his parents will get it
if Syrian says they don't need it
they're rich Milo says then they'll
understand
so anyway
he becomes this evil character in one of
the episodes
Milo contracts with the Nazis to bomb
his own base
right now this is a this is a
mind-bending problem because what Milo
does is he reasons the Germans are going
to bomb the base
anyway anyway they're gonna do it and
people are gonna get killed and Milo can
bomb the base as a contractual matter
and he can make sure that nobody gets
hurt
it's like we're gonna do it for you
right and you're going to pay us right
and so we'll do your work for you
right and so my point is
the market has a mind-bending logic
not all of the logic is tolerable right
you can make a defense of Milo
minderbinder bombing his own base
because the point is the base is going
to get bombed and nobody's going to get
killed this way it's a moral good
somebody's gonna do it and I did it
better right
and my point is the corruption that we
see and the role that it plays in our
history which we will never fully
understand is such a thing whatever
Market forces cause people to fear that
democracy was going to upend good
processes for no reason I mean and this
does happen right we see absolutely
nonsensical stuff warning stickers over
everything right if warning stickers
actually save lives then too many
warning stickers kills people because
you don't read warning stickers anymore
right so we see a proliferation of
warning stickers that originally came
from some honorable impulse but is just
gotten out of control the warning
stickers have been found by the state of
California to cause cancer
that would be good I bet they do if you
eat enough of them but
um but anyway the point is look there
are legitimate fears to have about
democracy journalism science right good
people can find themselves upended by
people nitpicking them to death on the
other hand without the processes that
are capable of nitpicking people to
death we are vulnerable to something
else which is the very stuff that the
founders of this country feared right
unbridled power in the hands of
something like a monarch
um descents into tyranny of all kinds
and so in any case
we're going to have to address the
question of the deep state does it exist
what is it made of and how can we
um
remove it so we can go back to the
frightening Prospect of democracy
let's figure it out all right
that on the next episode of dark no
really okay
you promised big man yeah
okay
um we're going to take a break and come
back with a live q a all right uh we're
gonna probably make it brief because
that was that we went on for a while
uh we didn't break the whole internet
but we broke Rumble apparently it's
about oh good it's back back I don't
even know what that means
um
so check out
um check out Natural Selections where uh
I read from a lot of Hugo girl this week
which I posted yesterday we've got
darkhorsestore.org where you can get a
variety of awesome merchandise printed
right here in the United States by this
lovely couple right here in the middle
of the country I've got psyop until
proven otherwise and
um
Pfizer the breakthroughs never stop
various various other things
you can of course get a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century uh anywhere that you can find
books and sign copies are available at
darvel's which is right here in the San
Juan Islands they are them online
and we've got our monthly private q a
coming up this Sunday at 11 A.M for one
more month we're going to be doing that
at my patreon and as soon by the end of
the day the dog is groaning in the
background it's like not patreon
I feel the same way about it since they
threw Carl Benjamin off I know
um well
really
um
but this uh this Sunday at 11 A.M
Pacific we're gonna be doing our two
hour private q a you can join us there
by coming to my patreon and uh before
the end of the day I will have up there
as well the ability for uh people to ask
questions at the 11 tier for that
private q a and then we're going to be
moving our the those conversations to
locals starting next month we haven't
figured out all the details but um that
will be happening there and of course
you can be watching the chat on locals
as well with the watch party or be
participating in the watch party there
um what else do we want to talk about
um sneezing dog sneezing so many so many
little distractions here
um soon also at locals we're going to
have access to a great Discord Community
right now you can get that through our
patreons and we're not going to be
shutting those down we're just going to
be moving a bunch of the stuff into into
locals uh but on the Discord you can
engage in honest conversations about
difficult topics join a book club I
don't mind with virtual happy hours and
karaoke lots of great people there I
also consider joining joining our
Discord
and uh let's see once oh and the people
on Discord send us a question every week
which is where we start our q and A's
with so
that Rumble exclusive q a that's going
to be happening soon assuming that
Rumble stays up we'll begin with a
question from the Discord once again
check out our wonderful sponsors this
week which were paleo Valley mud water
and Hillsdale College and remember that
we are supported by you our audience so
please subscribe like share give a
review
anywhere that reviews are found
um I don't know probably not like
Craigslist but
but I guess there are a lot of places
reviews are found that you probably
won't find us but anywhere you find us
characters we will get for it
we're not selling the podcast are we it
is used I previously enjoyed yes
all right um until we see you next time
you go to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]